[موسيقى]
بحب ارحب بضيفه حلقتنا اليوم لما المعايطه
من عمان لما طبعا ناشطه جدا في مجال دعم
مرضى السرطان من جميع المراحل العمريه وهي
ايضا محاربه حاربه السرطان مرتين وانتصرت
عليه وهي بهذا العمر اليافع اهلا وسهلا
فيك يا لمى معانا في كلام منطقي
اهلا اهلا فيكي طيب انا حبيت اعمل هاي
الحلقه بطريقه مختلفه
حبيت انه
الفت النظر لا تجربه ملهمه انت مريتي فيها
طبعا في قصص ملهمه كثير في ما يتعلق
بمحاربه السرطان وكيف ممكن انه تجربه
قاسيه مثل هيك انهم تتحول
شيء ايجابي بيفيد المجتمع بشكل كبير
والحقيقه هذا هو المثال اللي لقيته فيك
انا طلعت طبعا على مواقع او صفحاتك على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ما شاء الله عندك
اكثر من 700,000 متابع على انستغرام همم
وهذا غير طبعا المنصات الاخرى همم يمكن تك
توك كمان همم عندك يعني عدد كبير من
المتابعين همم ولفتني همم كل النشاطات
اللي بتقومي فيها والحملات همم لا دعم همم
مرضى السرطان من جميع النواحي ويمكن من
اكبر ناحيه هي الناحيه النفسيه حبه اسمع
تجربتك اذا بتحكي لنا اكثر عنك وعن رحلتك
مع السرطان
تجربتي مع المراه كانت في عمره صغير وانا
بعتبر حالي
بمثل صوره عن كثير ناس شباب بنات نساء
رجال حتى الاطفال ليوصل صوتهم بطريقه
صح
المرض اول سنه جامعه بالفصل الثاني من
الجامعه كان دخولي على الجامعه مع دخولي
على قصه جديده بحياتي
اقل من 48 ساعه هيك الحياه لما كل
الاحداثيات الحياه
هو هذا الكيس بعتبروه الاختبار الحقيقي
انا كنت بعمري صغير مش كثير بعرف يعني
احنا مجتمعاتنا
بهذاك العمر يعني بس كنا نحكي هداك المرض
نجيب سيرته الله يبعده عنا والمرض عادت
حتى لو ادمن ما بنعرف عنه دائما الاخرين
ما بيصير لاقلنا او للاشخاص اللي لاحبابنا
والناس المحيطين فينا
انه انا
كنت رايحه على المستشفى اعمل فحوصات لالي
وانا داخل عالم مستشفى متخصص بالكانسر لكن
عقلي ما عم تستوعب
لحظه معرفه كانت عن طريق الصدفه
كان كان غضبي لاني انا مو فاهمه شيء كان
غضبي على اهلي ليش
ما كنتي تعرفي
لانه اول ما عملت الخزعه
عن طريق التشخيص نوع الورم ااه انا بنت
وحيده فبتعرف احنا بنشتماعات على الفكره
عن البنت الوحيده انها بنت دلوعه ممم
بتتحمل خبر
الموضوع الموضوع
فانا عرفت عن طريق الصدفه ان الممرض كان
عم بينادي انه مين لبى معي او مين لما هيك
متحمسه زيك كانه بالمدرسه
يعني جرعتك الكيماوي انه بكره او بعده هيك
بالضبط
فانا انه هون هاي الصدمه كانت عندي طبعا
زي اغلب مرضى الكانسر اول شيء نعمله روح
نمسك الموبايل
[موسيقى]
بعدين مثل مثل الناس كنت ادور على جوجل
انه ايش بالضبط شو يعني مرض الفوما او
كانتر الامفوما للاسف الجوجل برضه مش كثير
بيعمل لنا بالطريقه الصح ممكن
اذا انت نفسيتك
مش جاهزه وهلا انت حاسه بقمه السلبيه مرات
بتزيد المعروف عشان هيك دائما بنصح اي
مريض كانسر لما تسمع الخبر ما تروح يكون
اول اشي طريقك جوجل
بلشت الرحله طبعا مثلي مثل اي صبيه يكون
همها شعرها
وانا شعري
[موسيقى]
مثل اي بنت
اخترت اني انا احتفل بقصه شعري انه انا ما
بدي اروح على المستشفى اشوف شعري قدامي
[موسيقى]
كنت رايحه على اول جلسه الي جاهزه لابسه
الباروكه
امي اعطتني كتاب اسمه قوه عقلك الباطل
دخلت على الجنسيه
[موسيقى]
كثير همم مسيره مهنيه برده بدك تلتقي
بشريك حياتك في في وقت من الاوقات همم
مستغربه انه كان يعني شو سر هي هي
الايجابيه اللي دخلت فيها على هذه المعركه
هل كانت نابعه من طبيعتك انت انسانه اصلا
همم كثير ايجابيه ام انه حسيتك انه في شيء
صار فيه
شيء اعطاني نوع من انواع القوه
العالم
يعني لما كانوا يسالوني شو بدك تصيري بس
تقدري انهم رائد الفضاء
صحيح باقدر اكون شيء طبعا
لما كمان كبيره انا كثير بامن اي انسان
بيصير اي حدا بحياته ربنا بنفس الوقت
بينزل عليه قوه وهما
في سكينه بس فيها هيك يعني الهدوء مش
الهدوء المريح الهدوء اللي بده يخفف عنك
عقلك عقلك بده يحميكي تحت تاثير الصدمه
فممكن ردت فعلي كانت عقلي عم يعطيني
المعلومه شوي شوي وكمان انا زي قلت لك انه
في على نقطه انه امي
لانه انا بلشت اقرا فيه دلوقت
[موسيقى]
كتب اثرت فيه
هذاك الوقت لما تصيري نوعا ما روح
تستقر عندك المشاعر انه ما تخافي
في شيء يمكن انت هلا مو فهمتيني بس هو
اكيد لخير تطمن طبعا وجود وجود وهذا وهذه
نقطه بحب اركز عليها وانت عم تحكي لنا
قصتك لانه قصتك لسه بعد ما انتهت ولكن
قديش كان امم دور
الاحباء اللي حواليك والدك والدتك اخوانك
همم صاحباتك محيطك مجتمعك همم
الدعم اللي ممكن يقدمه لك اياه وحتى هن
كيف بيتقبلوا الخبر وكيف بيتعامل معه
مهم بهاي المرحله خصوصا لانه للاسف وانا
عم بحكي هذا الحكي يعني عن تجربه شخصيه
سواء مع والدتي انا طبعا كنت حكيت في حلقه
السابقه بالحلقه اللي تحدثنا فيها عن
العلاج المناعي عن اصابه والدتي بمرض
السرطان الحمد لله همم صارت كثير احسن
ولكن ايضا عندي صديقه همم مقرب جدا همم
للاسف ايضا تم همم تشخيصها بمرض سرطان
الثدي من اشهر قليله وهي ام لطفل عمره
اربع سنوات
وتجربه كانت كثير قاسيه عليها وانتبهت انه
وهي طبعا لسه هلا في طور العلاج انتبهت قد
ايه حتى اللي حواليها كانوا هن نفسهم بدهم
مساعده نفسيه مش عارفين كيف يتعاملوا هن
مع الخبر لانهم نوع من انواع
الطب النفسي نوع من انواع
الجريفنج بيقولوا بالانجليزي اللي هو لما
همم انت
همم بتحزني وكانه في حاله موت لانه انتهت
مرحله من حياتك او في شيء انتهى وفي شيء
ثاني عم بيبلش فكل المراحل اللي النفسيه
اللي بتمر فيها بتعاطي مع الموت برده نفس
الشيء بتعاطي مع خبر بهذا ال- هول همم مثل
مرض السرطان كيف كانت تجربتك في موضوع
السبورت الدعم من محيطك
انا ممكن هاي القصه شويه هيك تكون
تستغربوها بس انا اول مره قررت اخفي
الموضوع عن والدي والدي كان عامل عمليه
قلب وكانوا اهل السنه الجديد على بلد
ثانيه في بريطانيا اخواني طالعين يدرسوا
من جديد
لحالك يعني
الشيء الوحيد اللي انا طلبته من امي اذا
بدك
وخصوصا انه كان عامل عمليه قلب جديد
[موسيقى]
همم
هو يعرف باول مره يوم ما تشاكيت
بعد الساعه 9
اشهر الاول اول مره وسبتي بالسرطان تعالجت
لمده تسعه اشهر على بين ما همم يعني وصلتي
لمرحله الشفاء
نعم اكيد طب كيف يعني احكي لنا عن هيك
محطات فيها طبعا نحن بنحكي عن التجربه
الاولى راح نيجي للتجربه الثانيه احكينا
على المحطات فيها محطات كانت رفعتك لفوق
عرفتي نفسيا
كثير احلى
زي دقت كثير ما يهكن همه كثير
همه اليوم يمر وهو عم بتنفسه قدر يقوم
منتفخه وما يكون موجوع ياكل لقمه بسيطه ما
فيه تعقيدات لان احنا هلا عم نمر فيها
بحياتنا ههه همم دعم الدعم النفسي
والمعنوي من قرايبي من اصحابي همم لاني
انا كنت رافضه تماما سواء امي
او باي مرحله
لسبب بحالك
فعلا
24 ساعه انا كان عندي هذه بشويه النظره
انه انا متاكده اذا اهلي راحوا معي راح
يكونوا الكيماوي عم بمشي بجسمي ويمكن انا
اكون عم بفكر بشيء ثاني امي عم تتوجع عني
همم اخترت انه انا اكون بهذا الموضوع واني
بس ارجع على البيت العنايه انا تحتاجها
اخذها منهم بس اخترت كل مره اروح لحالي لا
حد طبعا في كثير اشياء في ايام كانت تكون
كثير صعبه
يعني اعراض جانبيه من العلاج الكيماوي
سيئه جدا وبحاجه الواحد معه يعني مش بس
لدعموا نفسكم ولكن جسدي لهم كمان
هذا شيء يمكن ساعدك مع انه كان يمكن صعب
عليك
ممكن
على الجامعه
بس انا بهذا الموضوع
ويصير حقيقه
انه انا ما اترك الجامعه مع انه الفصل
الثاني اللي بعده اييه وصلت مناعتي
يعني
اضطريت اني ما راح ما اروح الجامعه على
فتره كثير طويله واضطريت اسقط للف
صل فهي معاناه مريضه
بالوجع والتعب في مجتمع في حياه بره في
احكام مطلقه في نظره شفقه كلها الظروف
النفسيه اللي مريض الكانسر بيكون بيمر
فيها
بوجهه نظري هو القادر والاولى بانه يعلم
الانسان شو يعني حياه لانه اللي يقدر على
مواجهه كلها ويطلع منها سوي عقليا ونفسيا
ومتفائل هذا انسان ترفع له القبعه صراحه
مضبوط فانا يعني ناس كثير عم بلتقي فيهم
بشوفهم همم
زوج همم بتشتغل ببيتها وبتشتغل بالشغلها
تروح تتعالج هاي هي انسانه فخر فخر لكل
حدا بالحياه طبعا طبعا هو يقال زي ما
بيقولوا يعني ما بيقوي الحديد الا النار
في النهايه وهي الاوقات الصعبه هي اللي
بتبين المعادننا
وبتعطينا فرصه
انه نكبر او انه نطور ويكون في عنا همم
ادوات واسلحه منحرف فيها الحياه بشكل فعال
اكثر باعتقد
هاي هاي المرحله الاولى بعدين يعني دكاتره
طبعا بانه صرتي وبعدها هيك
السنه البيبي ترجع يمشي يتدرب يمشي
ايش رايك بدي ارجع على الحياه بس للاسف
برضو كان في مشكله ان الناس
من الاشياء اللي كنت عم بعاني منها انه
انا ما عم بفهم الناس بره يعني
خلينا ناخذها على دائره صغيره انا
وصاحباتي بس محور نقاش ما يكون الساعه
كامله عن الشعر لما تكون البنت تنتقد
شعرها للماكسنت
انها تحلق شعرها راح يكون مش قادره معاها
مش قادره حتى الحقيقه هذا الشيء كثير اثر
فيه بالسنه
مش قادره اتقبل المشاكل اللي الناس عن
تشكيلتها لانه اذا حدا عمل حادث بسيط خبط
سيارته بيكون يوم كله همم
يعني كانه صار سلبي جدا
هاي الامور اثرت عليك
لما بعد المراد بس بعدها بتذكر جمله كثير
مهمه همم من دكتور امم يعني بالمركز قال
لي لما بدك همم رحت انا قلت له قلت له
دكتور انا عندي اكتئاب قال لي حلو جايب
شخص حالك
عندي اكتئاب قال لي طيب كيف قررت عندك
اكتئاب قلت له الناس بدها اشياء بالحياه
انا ما بدي اياها الناس بتدور على الرفاه
هي بتدور بتكون هكلانه هم بكرا انا مش
قادره احكي لها بكره بكره عم بسكر بس
بالدقيقه
فالتفاصيل هاي والثانيه صرت عم بحس انه
انا يمكن انا غلط
فما بعدين بتذكر الدكتور كتب لي بيت من
رباعيات الخيام بس للاسف هلا مو متذكرته
وهو عن الحياه كتب لي اياه
وبعدي حديث من طول بيني وبينه فوق الثلاثه
اغلى الناس
تستصعبي الحروف
[موسيقى]
اكبر مشكله ممكن يكونوا هم مارقين فيها
خطه السياره فما بتقدري تطلبي منه يعيش
نفسه مرحله الوعي والفكر اللي هلا انت
ههه طيب وبعد هيك بعد كيفك كيف قدرتي
تطلعي او تتعاملي مع يعني انت هيك طلعتي
من مشكله طبيه المشكله الاجتماعيه نوعا ما
كيف اتعملت معاها وشو صار معك بعدها
كنت بعدني مثلا ما في اكيد شعر على راسي
مساء احط الباروكه واذا دخلت محل ويكونوا
البنات
كثير حلوه ههه
كانت رداد فعل كثير عفويه ما اكثر ما ما
اكل كثير مشاعري
دغري من قلبي على لساني فهذا الموضوع كثير
مريح الواحد بقدر هو بروحه اولويه كل شيء
بحياته لانه بتذكر انا بتعالى من الاشياء
اللي هيك فجاه
كان عندي التهاب كثير
طب لما انت قشطه تفتحيه
فكرت انه انا الجسم الجسد اللي انا عايشه
فيه هلا ما بقدر اسيطر عليه ولا قادره
وموجوع بس الشيء الوحيد اللي بدون نقاش
راح دايما اطير بالي عليهم بشكل
عقلي وروحي
هدول شغلتين كثير مهمين
فمشان هيك لو شو ما صار همم
يعني دائما بكون بفكر انه هذا الموضوع
كثير مهم لازم اذيه انتبه على دول المنطقه
الحقيقه يعني واضح انك همم ما بعرف اذا هي
تجربه اللي اعطيتك ولا انت اصلا بطبيعتك
على ما يبدو انسان ناضج كثير اكثر من عمره
لحتى تقدري تفكري بهذا العمر اصلا
بالتعامل مع ما لا نستطيع ان همم نتحكم
فيه
ما نستطيع ان يسيطر علي
انا نوعا ما بيسموني الطفل المعجزه انا
كمان انا كمان مولوده سته اشهر انا ما
كملت تسعه اشهر لما
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
كيف
تجربه مره اخرى رجع
رجع لي رجع لي المرض بعد تقريبا سنه
[موسيقى]
كمان
في مرات مصطلحات انا دائما بقول ما تحكي
ولا مريض الكانسر ما تقولوا له اذا طبت
يعني مليون بالميه ما برجع هي الخلايا
السرطانيه موجوده في كل الجسم لكن في لحظه
بترجع بتصير انه هي اكثر فلما تزرع
تفكير مريض انه مستحيل يرجع لك
انت مش دائما انك بتكون عم بتساعده ما
تعطي كلمه مس
تحيل خلي
انسان عشان هيك في شيء اسمه فحوصات دوريه
دائما لازم الواحد يعملها لكن برضو بهاي
المره
راح اشرح لك هلا ليه انا صرت اكثر
بالرمثانيات ما بعرف
بتصدق ولا لا بس هو هذا اللي صار معي انا
بس اجاني شعور اجاني شعور انه انا مش تمام
وكان صار لي بس شهرين
ورحت لدكتوري وقلت له بليز انا بدي ارجع
اعيد قال لي لما النصر لنا شهرين يعني
مريض الكانسر بعد هذه التجربه سير عنده
انه يعني
فحوصات بس هالمره
[موسيقى]
الدكتور ما صدقتني
مثلا ممكن اجيب الطريقه الاولى والثانيه
وبتركوا بالعاده مثلا زراعه النخاع لاخر
شيء مثلا ممكن يكون كخيارات
بس لانه كنا مترددين بين زراعه النخاع
وبين اخذ نوع الكيماوي الكتير قوي اضطروا
يعملولي ليه هو سحب الخلايا المراعيه على
اساس اذا اضطر ويرجعوا يعملوا لي زراعه
املاقيها
فثار انه انا انسحبت الخلايا لكن اخذت نوع
الكيماوي كتير
التعب مضاعفه
يعني عادي انه انحرم من الاكل والشرب شهر
ونص شهرين اضلني على
الصباح اعيش في غرفه العزل
الامراض والالتهابات والتقرحات وتكون
اضعاف مضاعفه واحنا عم نحكي عن كل هذا
الوقت انا كنت بالايام اللي اكون مصحصحه
فيها اكون بجامعه
[موسيقى]
وارجع حالي على مثلا برده
رجعت اعاده نفس الاصاله كان في حجم كبير
كانت اقصى بكثير
كثير كثير
لدرجه في فتره من كثر الصدمه مكانه تقويه
علي وقفت عن الحكي
بطلت احكي
وهذا كله
لوحدك يعني لا والد ولا والد ولا اخوان
حوالي
خلاص يعني اهلي صار عندهم فكره عن الموضوع
لكن المريض الكانسر بيكون لما يكون بيتعرض
لدرجه كتير كتير
اكيد اكيد طبعا ولكن هينا شايفينك قدامنا
زي القمر
الاواعي جاهزه ومحطوطه بالسياره فيها كل
الاشياء اللي انا بحبها
لما اليوم عندك ادخال ااه كنت انه بالضبط
الممرضين الدكاتره المرضى صفهم عادي
في اخر الليل نسهر سهرتنا مع بعض نقضي
الوقت مع
بعض
حلوه انه اكيد في شيء ايجابي في كل تجربه
سلبيه حتى واحنا عملنا من مر فيها بغض
النظر عن شو رح نطلع منها ولكن
مثل الدنيا ما في لاخر مطلق ولا شر مطلق
ولا
حزن مطلق ولا فرح مطلق همم
كلها تتراوح بنسب مختلفه يعني ما بين
قطبين زي ما بقولوا طيب بعد هيك لمعه همم
في فتره العلاج وبعد هيك الحمد لله تمتعتي
بالشفاء بعد قد ايه
خبر
الغرفه العسل
[موسيقى]
طبيعي كنت قاعده ومبسوطه وعم بضحك مع
الممرضين والممرضات
وبيلاحظوا بس بلحظه راح النفس
فجاه بطلت قادره انا اتنفس
وطلع انه اجاني فايروس نتيجه نقص المناعات
وقفوا عند الرئتين وصفيته
كل التجربتي مع مرض الكانسر بكفي وتشربتي
بالايسي المختلفه لانه الانسان دائما
بيكون مثلا شايف يعني كل حاجه كان شايف
انه كانسر انه ممكن يقضي عليها ويمكن ما
تعيش لكن انا بلحظه فايروس
[موسيقى]
48 ساعه لا يحاولوا يرجع
فال 48 ساعه هاي كانت عباره عن حياه كامله
فيها
فيها همم عم بنعيشوني مرتين
فيها انه طلبوني قالوا لي شو احلام
دفتر رسم والوان كانت هي التجربه لاصعب
بالاي سي يو بس الحمد لله
ما طلعنا نستنى لل 48 ساعه
بهذيك اللحظه
اتذكرت الكتاب اللي اهدتني اياه امي
احاول افكر انه طيب
الله عاطينا اياه انه ايش عنجد ممكن انا
اقدر هلا افكر خليني افكر انه هلا
فعلا الرئتين بدهم يش
تغلوا وفعلي كل شيء بقدره رب العالمين
كنتي كنتي في وعيك وانت بالعنايه المركزه
ازاي ما كنتيش فاضيه
اعيش
فكان عندي الحياه
الرئتين بترجع بيتنا
والحمد لله
وقفت على رجلي كل شيء باراده ربنا ورجعت
الي صحتي وعافيتي
وصف من هذاك اليوم عاهد وعد على نفسي اني
اكون جنبك كل مريض
نفسيا ومعنويا وماديا استطعت
وفعلا هذا اللي عملتيه لانه انت يعني
نشيطه جدا في مجال
الحملات سواء كان توعيه او الدعم لاطفال
اللوكيميا مثلا شفت على صفحتك على مواقع
التواصل بنفس الوقت
بتلمي تبرعات ايضا عملت حمله
لم تبرعات لمراكز ايضا تعنى به السرطان
حسينا اكثر عن هذا الجانب كيف قدرتي
تحاولي هذه التجربه القاسيه اللي حاربتي
فيها مشاهده فيها مرتين واللي بينهم كمان
همم لغايه ما خرجتي بهاي همم النتيجه
الايجابيه المفيده
اااه صراحه بعد ما خلصت التجربه مع مرض
الكانسر
الظل راح اعمل الفحوصات اشوف اطفال
فاقولها الطفل يعني احنا كبار ومستحمل طيب
ايش ناقصه ايش محتاج لما صرت اتعامل مع
الاطفال اكثر الطفل
معك
بده يتعامل مع الاطفال الثانيين بطريقه
كثير طبيعيه
يعرفوني وانا لاني كنت بدرس اطفال كمان
فعندي طريقه والاسلوب اني اعرف اوصل
اذا الطفل المجلد
بتاعته ام ايه ياكل اكل هلتي فقلت كثير
همم الواسطه بين الطفل والام حلو ف- همم
بعدين بيوم من الايام وهو الموضوع ما وقف
بس على همم الاطفال في كمان شباب وبنات
سميهم عيله الثانيه هم جزء لا يتجزء كنت
معهم برحلتهم مع المرض في منها ما خسرتهم
بس انا ما بعتبر اني خسرتهم على طول لانه
روحهم
معي وكل شيء بعمله روحهم
لكن بقاعده من اعدادنا قالوا لي لما ليه
متكبر الموضوع ولي لما تعمليه مبادره
ما بعرف شو اسميها قالوا لي انت شو بتعملي
بتلمينا وبتعطينا امل
جميل
[موسيقى]
انه
يرجع ويندمجه انا مثل ما قلت لك اول ما
خلصت اول سنه كثير
بدي ارجع على المستشفى هو
فلما ينخلطوا مع الطلاب الحقيقيين اداهم
يمر بصعوبه فقل هاي التفاصيل الحمد لله
همم على طول في اشياء كثير حلوه بنعملها
مع عيلتين همم كمان تقريبا 10 ايام اذا
بتشوفونا على اكونت لمده امل راح يكون
برده في فعاليات كثير حلوه للاطفال همم
باحب اعبي يومهم يكون كامل حتى بالاكل
اللي يتدرب همم
وهم سبب سعادتي هما سبب السعاده اللي
الحب الغير مشروط
يعني جانب من الدعم يمكن اهلهم غير قادرين
همم
الكيرفرس غير قادرين على انهم يعطوه نتيجه
لانهن كمان بيكونوا همم يعني في قمه التعب
سواء كان النفسي او الجسدي من مراعاه مريض
سرطان وهن بحاجه نفسهم لا همم
مشاريعك المستقبليه يا لما انت طبعا ناشطه
في الاردن ولكن سمعت انك راح يكون في لك
نشاطات ايضا في في الخليل في دبي تحديدا
وان شاء الله تكبر هاي المبادره ومبادرات
همم اخرى يعني ممكن تكون فيها وبتشمل
العالم العربي كله
اكيد اكيد لما اتامعل هدفها الخير والدعم
لاي انسان
بغض النظر مش بس مرضى الكانسر ان شاء الله
هيكون عندي كمان حمله قريبا في عمان
معنيه
باللبس الشتوي للامن العائلات المستوره
فكره حلوه ولطيفه من الناس
المساعده والخير ما بيوقف بس على اي شيء
ممكن مرات يكون بكلمه
فبحس هدفي ودوري بس موجوده انا بالمجتمع
او على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي اني اكون
وسيده خير اهل الخير والناس المحترمه ان
شاء الله دائما تقدري همم هاي الوسيله
وتكوني هاي الوسيله الوسيله الخير وانت
فعلا كنتيها لانه حتى الناس اللي همم
حواليك همم الهمتيهم بانهم يكون في عندهم
تطلعات مشابهه او حتى يدخل ويساعدوك في
مثل مبادرات انا حابه اقول لك قبل ما ننهي
الف مبروك همم لانه عزاء المتابعين عروس
جديده تزوجت من شهر تقريبا
والجميل في الموضوع اذا يعني بتدخلوا على
مواقع التواصل وصفحاتها مواقع التواصل
بتشوفوا قد ايه كمان زوجها منخرط معها في
هذه المبادرات اللي همم يعني نظره حياتها
لها
وان شاء الله دائره توسع اكثر واكثر واكثر
علامات
كثير همم يعني حسيت انه انا عم بحكي مع
صديقتي
عن جد ملهمه يعني همم لمسه قلبي بتمنى انه
همم تكون الهامه
الامل زي ما اسم مبادرتك كل المتابعين همم
شكرا كثير لك يا لمعه وان شاء الله اكيد
لما تيجوا دبي لازم يكون في قل لنا همم
جلسات يعني وحلقات قادمه على كلامك
شكرا
[موسيقى]